marcharon en lima y en el interior del
país en rechazo a lo que ellos
consideran un golpe de estado que ha
sacado de la presidencia a martín
vizcarra en varios manifestantes que
participaron en la jornada me dijeron
que ellos van a radicalizar la protesta
y no le van a dar tregua a manuel merino
hasta forzar su renuncia se realizaron
diversos incidentes y detenciones
arbitrarias la organización de esta de
la organización de las naciones unidas
le ha pedido a las autoridades que se
protejan los derechos humanos de los
manifestantes justamente el primer
ministro ántero flores un conservador de
78 años dijo que él no entendía en la
situación de los peruanos que
protestaban ante un cambio de gobierno